Where else are we were going to have today we're going to continue the state of
nature hubs.
His most famous discovery is most famous metaphor is most famous,
uh,
concept.
The end of class last time I can have my Hobbs is central problem is the problem
of authority.
What,
what makes authority possible?
What makes La Thought Authority legitimate?
And in order to answer that question,
I suggested he created,
uh,
this idea,
this metaphor again of a state of nature,
a statement in which he says we are naturally in Hobbs.
This state of nature is virtually the opposite of Aristotle's conception of the
natural and are the natural tea loss of man.
Uh,
it does not consist of our perfection,
a condition of our perfection as Aristotle believed,
but four hubs.
The state of nature is something like the condition of human life in the absence
of authority,
in the absence of any one to impose rules,
order law on us.
What,
what would human beings be like in such a condition,
a condition of the type that he imagined maintains in a periods of crisis,
civil war of the kind that was true of England and the 1640s.
And I suggested a at the end of last time that in many ways Hobbes,
his idea of a state of nature can be understood in a sense as an extension of
his scientific methodology set out in the opening chapters of the book.
Uh,
let's imagine as he says,
you know,
human beings as if they were in a sort of laboratory tests to let's strip human
beings of all their social ties and customs and traditions.
Let's see what they would be like a in abstraction from all of the social and
political relationships which they enjoy and see how they would interact with
one another almost as chemical properties.
And you can see,
uh,
Hobbs working along that line.
But I would say this,
uh,
as it were,
scientific or Prodo scientific,
a conception of the state of nature is not the whole answer to this story
because underlying Hobbs is a conception of the state of nature is a powerful
moral conception,
a moral idea of the human being.
And that's what I want to talk a little bit about today.
Hobbs is a moralist,
uh,
which seems odd in some ways.
How could grim and,
uh,
door,
old Thomas Hobbs be regarded as he more or less or someone with a moral
conception of human nature and the human condition.
But that's what I want to suggest to you today.
Uh,
the term in,
in a sense in which we might better characterize his conception of the state of
nature is one of individuality.
MMM.
Hub shows us what it is to exercise the qualities of moral agency that is to
say,
to do for ourselves rather than to have things done for us or for you hubs
introduced into our moral language,
the idiom of individuality in this concept,
the concept of what it is to be an individual.
A moral agent isn't really,
it's really not older than,
or at least not much older than the 17th century until the renaissance,
or not much later,
people considered themselves primarily not as individuals,
but as members,
members of a particular family,
of a cast,
of a guild,
of a particular religious order of a city,
uh,
or so on.
The idea that one is first of all,
a self with an eye,
an ego,
uh,
would have been regarded as unintelligible.
Uh,
and even as late as the 19th century,
uh,
Alexis de Tocqueville in democracy in America says,
individualism is a recent expression arising from a new idea.
That idea appeared new to Tocqueville as late as the 19th century.
And this idea of the individual I want to suggest is at least in part,
it may be in large part traceable back to Hobbs.
Okay.
What is Hobbes is individual
hubs conceived us,
uh,
through a process of abstraction from the web of attachments in which we find
ourselves we are beings.
He argues again in the opening chapters whose fundamental characteristics is
human beings are willing and choosing.
We are beings for whom the exercise of the will is a pre eminent feature and
much of our happiness as human beings depends upon our capacity to exercise our
will and our ability for choice.
Life hubs is an exercise and continual willing and continual choosing that may
be temporarily interrupted but can never come to an end except with the end of
life itself.
Hobbes is individuality or individualism is closely connected to this conception
of a human being or human wellbeing.
Uh,
as success in the competition for the goods of life.
Continual success.
He writes in chapter six,
continual success in obtaining those things which a man from time to time desire
with is what is called happiness or Felicity.
Uh,
our wellbeing depends on our,
uh,
ability to achieve the objects of our desires.
Uh,
the objects of our choices for there is no such thing.
He continues as perpetual tranquility of mind.
No such thing is perpetual tranquility.
Why we live here?
Because life itself is button motion and can never be without desire nor without
fear.
No more than without sense.
These are the characteristics of human life,
sense,
fear and desire.
Continual desire for one thing after another.
When for Hobbes,
this fact is not simply a physical or factual description of human behavior,
but it is a moral condition because we are each of us bundles of activity and
initiative of likes and dislikes of desires and aversions.
Life for Hobbs is competition or struggle,
not just over scarce resources,
although that might be part of the struggle.
But for honors,
for anything else that a person might value or esteem,
Hobbes is fascinated,
uh,
and is again,
like Montaine and a number of others.
He is fascinated with the diversity,
the sheer diversity,
multiplicity of human desires.
What leads one person to laughter leads another person to tears.
What leaves one person to piety and prayer nee leads another person to ridicule
and so on.
And so on.
Even moral terms.
Hobbes says terms like good and evil,
he says,
are expressions of our individual likes and dislikes.
Uh,
we liked something he says,
not because it is good,
but we call something good because we like it.
And the same with qualities of,
uh,
other,
other moral qualities and attributes.
They are expressions for him of our psychological states,
uh,
and aspirations.
And it is this individualism,
uh,
that is,
the ground of the general competition that we all experience for the object of
our desires.
That he says the net or from this he infers that the natural condition is one of
competition,
of struggle,
of enmity and of war.
In a famous passage from chapter 11,
he posits as he puts it,
a general inclination of all mankind,
a perpetual and restless desire of power after power that sees it only in death.
This is as he puts it,
a general inclination of all mankind,
a district constant restlessness and motion and expression of our individuality
and what I have been calling Hobbs individualism is connected.
In fact,
they've been,
is underwritten by.
Another attribute that he did is central to hubs that his,
his skepticism,
like many of the great early modern philosophers,
Montana,
Descartes,
Spinosa Hobbes was obsessed with the question about what can I know or maybe put
a different way,
what am I entitled to believe?
And there are many passages in Leviathan nit testify to Hobbs is fundamentally
skeptical view of knowledge,
right?
Uh,
he is a skeptic not because he believes that all that we can have no foundations
for our beliefs,
whatever,
but he is a skeptic in the sense that there can be no on his view transcendent
or non human foundations for our beliefs.
We cannot be certain he thinks of the ultimate foundations of our knowledge and
this explains,
you may have wondered about this.
This explains the importance he attributes to such things as naming and attach
and correct definitions to things for reason.
He writes in a famous passage for reason is nothing but reckoning that is adding
and subtracting the consequences of general names agreed upon knowledge.
In other words,
it's four hubs,
a human construction and it is always subject to what human beings can be made
to agree upon.
And that skeptical view of knowledge or at least skeptical view of the
foundation of knowledge has far reaching consequences for him if if all
knowledge according to Hobbs,
ultimately rests on agreement about shared terms.
He infers from the there.
Our reason,
our rationality has no share in what Plato or Aristotle would have called the
divine nous.
The divine intelligence,
uh,
our reason has within it no spark of divinity.
Uh,
our reason does not testify to some kind of inner voice of conscience or
anything that would purport to give it some kind of in Duke biteable foundation.
Uh,
such certainty as we have about anything is for Hobbs always provisional,
uh,
discovered on the basis of experience and subject to continual revision in the
light of further experience.
And that again,
experiential conception of knowledge.
That kind of skepticism about the foundations of knowledge has further
implications for Hobbes is views on such things as religion and religious
toleration.
Uh,
there are no signs or fruit of religion,
he says,
but in man only says in chapter 12.
That is to say the causes of religion can be traced back and are rooted in the
restlessness of the human mind in its search for causes.
And it is because he says we are born ignorant of causes.
We are ignorant of the causes of things that we are led to search out beginnings
and origins.
And this leads us ultimately,
he says,
to posit the existence of God who is a so to speak,
uh,
the first cause of all things Hobbes does not,
despite this kind of rationalistic view of religion and his view that religion
has its origin,
again,
in the restlessness and the UN,
uh,
of,
of the human mind hubs doesn't deny the possibility of revelation or some kind
of direct communication of God to us.
But what he does deny is that this revel is that anyone who has claimed to
receive such a revelation,
he denies that any such person has the right to impose that view on anyone else
because nobody else can correctly,
uh,
have the means to verify a person's claim to revelation.
No one can impose their claim of revealed knowledge on another.
Does this make hubs and atheist as many would have maintained in his day?
No.
Uh,
it makes him a skeptic about,
uh,
about the,
revealed religion.
Okay.
So it is because of this individualism and skepticism.
A view of life is willing and choosing that there are in the state of nature,
so to speak,
no standards to adjudicate conflicts that the central issue of politics arises.
Namely what makes authority possible.
How are people who are biologically,
uh,
individually constituted?
So,
so to speak.
How can any of them ever be any of us ever be capable of obeying common rules or
having moral obligations to one another?
How is that possible?
Hobbs to ask,
uh,
in a,
in a manner of speaking on almost every page of the book,
but before answering that question,
uh,
consider a little further hubs,
his account of the state of nature and what makes it seem like a plausible
starting point?
Uh,
to answer the question of what makes authority possible
to say that the state of nature,
uh,
consists primarily of individuals with again,
diverse likes,
dislikes,
beliefs,
opinions,
and the like.
Uh,
is not to say that the state of nature is a state of isolation as it sometimes
attributed to him and people in the state of nature may have regular and
continual contact with one another.
It is just that their relations are unregulated.
They are unregulated by law,
they are unregulated by authority.
The state of nature is simply a kind of condition of maximum,
uh,
insecurity,
an unregulated market with no,
um,
with,
with no common laws or rules to uh,
to,
to sustain it.
The emphasis on the individual is just another way of saying,
again,
unlike Aristotle that no one has a natural authority over anyone else.
Uh,
relations of authority exist only by so to speak,
the consent or the will of the governed.
And the fact that relations in the state of nature are unregulated for him makes
it a container is synonymous with making it a condition of war of all against
all.
And his famous formulation.
Now you might look at that formulation.
A state of war is won against of all against all.
And you might say that such a condition of,
of civil war,
of maximum insecurity,
of the total breakdown of condition of rules and laws is if anything,
the state of the acception.
How often does that really occur?
Uh,
in,
in our experience in human life.
But hubs like Machiavelli is we saw likes to take the exceptional situation and
turn it in to the norm.
It becomes the normal condition.
State of security,
insecurity,
fear,
conflict in the leg.
This is not to say again that the state of nature for Hobbes is one of permanent
fighting,
but it is one of permanent fear and distrust and he asks his readers,
I mean,
there's so many wonderful passages in this book.
It's just happens to be one of my particular favorites.
He asks us readers,
if you don't believe me,
again,
think of his skepticism.
Don't,
don't believe me.
He says,
check your own experience and see if I'm not right and this is what he writes.
Let him him the reader,
therefore ask himself Hobbs rights.
When taking a journey.
He arms himself and seeks to go well,
accompanied when going to sleep.
He locks his doors even when in his house and even went in his house.
He locks his chest and this when he knows,
he says there'd be laws and public officer's arm to avenge all injuries shall be
done to him.
What opinion hubs asks he has of his fellow subjects when he rides armed.
You know,
what does that say about your thinking about your,
your fellow citizens?
When you arm yourselves going for a trip of his fellow citizens,
when he locks his doors at night or of his children and servants,
when he locks his chest,
does he not therefore as much accused mankind by his action as I do by my words,
you can see the,
the mischievousness of Hobbs in that,
you know,
in that delightful passage.
What,
what about you?
He says,
and this is not in some kind of state of nature,
this is in a completely,
you know,
fully functioning society.
Uh,
when you go go armed,
when you lock your doors,
when you lock,
when you lock your chests at night,
don't you just don't,
your actions and your experience simply confirm what,
what I'm,
what I'm what I'm saying.
And this tells us another thing about the state of nature,
which it is easy to forget.
The state of nature,
at least for Hobbes,
is not some kind of primitive anthropological.
A datum that we find by,
you know,
going back in time somehow Russo,
we'll speak about it more this way for Hobbes,
the state of nature exists.
He says,
whenever a authority is not enforced,
the state of nature fully continues in many ways.
Oddly even in civil society,
he says,
whenever we have reason to believe that our lives or our properties or ourselves
are not secure.
Uh,
and so that,
that's,
that's the,
the,
the uh,
in in fact,
we,
we can never be fully free of the fear and the anxiety and uncertainty of,
of,
of the state of nature,
even even within to some degree of fully constituted a civil society.
The only exception to this of course in Hobbs is a account of the state of
nature when he says,
don't you lock your doors at night are of course a Yale students,
uh,
living here on campus who are so trusting that they never locked their doors at
night in their entryways and so on.
And then of course,
are always stunned to find when something is stolen from them.
How could this be?
How this be a,
and I tell him,
lock your doors,
but they still don't believe me.
Uh,
maybe you'll now believe hubs if you don't believe me.
So the state of nature,
it's a state of insecurity.
It's a state of conflict.
How do we get out of it?
This is,
you know,
of course that the huge issue that Hobbs asks,
uh,
for the rest of,
for much of the book,
what do we do to get out of this state of nature to enter a condition of civil
society and civilized life?
How do I give up my right to do whatever is in my power to secure my person or
my possessions when I have no expectation?
You might say that others around me are prepared to do so as well.
This is sort of a classic example of what a economists and other people like
them called the prisoner's dilemma.
You know,
why should I act in such a way if I have no expectation or reasonable,
uh,
expectation that those around me will,
will,
will reciprocate.
Hobbs is,
members of a state of nature seem to be in a classic prisoner's dilemma problem.
Maybe we can say,
we could say,
or Hobbs could say that,
uh,
laying down our right to do all things,
in seeking peace with others is the rational thing to do.
Uh,
in the condition of nature,
we are all rational actors and therefore it is rational for us to seek and to
desire peace.
But note that that is exactly what Hobbes does not say.
You does not say this far from having a sort of a rational actor model of
politics.
He,
he operates with an irrational actor model.
He assumes that it is not reason,
but our passions,
uh,
that are the dominant force of human psychology,
our desires,
our aversions,
our passions.
And although I've said that Hobbs has emphasize the diversity of our passions,
there are still two main passions that he feels universally dominate human
nature.
And these two passions are pride and fear.
Okay.
Pride and fear.
These are the hubs,
Ian,
equivalents of that too.
Great.
Huet what Machiavelli called humors.
You remember the two humors of the two big of the two great social classes that
the desires of,
of the rich and powerful as it were to rule over others.
And the desire of the,
of the week,
not to be ruled,
Machiavelli called those the two.
You Mari,
the two,
the two humors,
the two groups and Hobbs similarly with a kind of model.
He's a great political psychologist.
Uh,
the,
the two great passions of pride and fear,
pride,
he says,
is the passion for preeminence,
the desire to be first and also to be seen to be first.
Uh,
in the great race of life.
Prideful people.
He tells us are those overflowing with confidence about their own abilities to
succeed.
And we all know people like this.
Don't wait like Yale students.
They're all overflowing with confidence,
kind of Alpha types.
Uh,
Machiavelli might call them sort of manly men,
uh,
who,
fully confident about their abilities.
And yet hubs is a great debunker of human pride.
Pride is equivalent to what he calls a vanity or vain glory.
It is a kind of exaggerated confidence in one's own power and ability.
It is pride,
the desire to Lord it over others and to have one one's superiority acknowledged
by others.
That is the great problem for hubs to be averted.
But if pride for him,
uh,
is one of his great universal passions.
So is its opposite.
Uh,
fear hubs makes the fear of death that may come to us at any time in a state of
nature.
Perhaps he exaggerates this,
but making it a pure state of nature is a kind of existential condition in which
death can come to you at almost any moment.
Uh,
and but there is more to fear than then.
This simply fear of death,
although Hobbs emphasizes and dramatically perhaps overemphasizes fear is not
just the desire to avoid death,
but to avoid losing a,
you might say again in the great race of life to avoid losing and to be seen as
a loser.
Uh,
it is the desire to avoid the shame of being seen by others as losing out
somehow.
There was a social quality clearly to both of these passions,
pride and sh and in fear one again,
the desire to have one's preeminence is steamed by others.
Fear that desire to avoid shame and dishonor.
How we are seen by others is a crucial cardinal.
Part of Hobbs is moral psychology and each of us,
he says contain these do not simply represent two classes of individuals,
two classes of persons.
Each of us contains these two warring,
you might say,
elements within us,
both self assertion,
uh,
and fear of the consequence of self assertion.
The question is for Hobbes.
How do we,
uh,
how do we tame these passions?
How do we tame these passions?
It is most of our pride that Hobbes wants to tame.
And of course the very title of his book,
Leviathan he tells us later on comes from what you remember.
Where does it come from?
Who remembers
passage from what?
Joe Book of Job,
where he refers to Leviathan as king of the children of pride.
The book is based on Biblical Metaphor about over coming or subduing.
Pride
is the great Marcellus wireless says in the film pulp fiction pride never helps.
It only hurts
you.
Remember that?
That's magnificent speech.
Fear hub says is the passion to reckon on is the passion to be recognized.
It is fear not reason that leads us to abandon the state of nature and sue for
peace,
the passions that inclined men to peace hubs,
right?
Our fear of death.
This is not to say that Hobbes believes fear to be the naturally stronger of the
two passions in fact,
far from it.
Uh,
there are many people,
uh,
certainly even around us who,
who Hobbes believes do not fear death as they should.
The proud aristocrat who prefers death before dishonor the religious zealot,
uh,
prepared to sacrifice his life and of course those of others,
in order to achieve the rewards of heaven.
And of course just the risk taking individual,
uh,
who you know,
seeks to climb Mount Everest,
uh,
just for the,
honor and esteem involved.
And it is part of the broader educational or pedagogic function,
uh,
of Leviathan to help us see,
Hobbes thinks the dangers of pride and the advantages of peace.
Properly directed fear leads to peace.
Fear is the basis even of what Hobbs calls the various laws of nature that lead
us to civil society.
The laws of nature for carbs are described as a precept or a general rule of
reason.
It every man ought to endeavor piece and it is out of fear that we begin to
reason and see the advantages of society.
Reason is dependent upon the passions upon fear.
The first and most fundamental law of nature he says is to seek peace and follow
it.
Not only should one seek peace,
but we have an obligation.
He says,
to lay down our arms,
to lay down our right to all things on the condition that others around us are
prepared to do so as well.
And Hobbes goes on to enumerate 19 laws of nature.
I won't,
I won't go into all of them.
19 laws of nature,
nature that constitute a kind of framework for establishing civil society.
These laws,
he even compares as his equivalent of the golden rule,
which he states in the negative do not do unto others.
What you would not have them do unto you hear is Hobbes is rewriting of the
golden rule in terms of these laws of nature.
But these raise a question for us as readers of Hobbs,
right?
Don't they?
What?
What is the status of the,
of the laws of nature?
What is the moral status if any of these laws,
hubs as we see sometimes,
right as a sort of scientist or prodo scientists for whom nature and one
supposes the laws of nature operate with the same kind of necessity as the laws
of physical attraction.
That that's how he often writes about human behavior.
That we obey the same laws of physical attraction as do any other bodies that we
might choose to describe.
They describe how bodies in motion always in necessarily behave these laws of
nature.
And yet at the same time Hobbs right is a moralist for whom the laws of nature
he calls precepts of reason or general rules according to which we are forbidden
to do anything destructive of life
in this tense.
The laws of nature as he described him appear to be moral laws with moral
commands commands you not to do anything that is destructive of life,
your own or that of others.
And his moral laws in this sense,
we have presumably the freedom to obey them or disobeyed them if they acted with
a kind of mechanical necessity or even geometric necessity.
They could not possibly be moral laws in that way.
They can only be moral if there is some semblance of human choice or will
expressed in the,
in the relationship our ability to do otherwise.
So these laws of nature seek peace and so on do not simply seem to be
descriptive of how people do behave.
They seem to be prescriptive of how people ought to behave.
Uh,
and this hubs even suggest at the end of Chapter 15,
when he writes about the of nature,
these dictates of reason.
Men,
you men used to call by the name laws,
but improperly for they are conclusions or theorems according to what conduces
to the conversation of mankind.
These used to be called laws of nature,
he says,
but improperly.
So if they are only improperly laws of nature,
why does Hobbs continue to use the term?
Why?
Why does he use this terminology of laws of nature?
In a sense,
this might simply be Hobbs is way of paying homage to the ancient tradition of
natural law.
Going back to the medieval scholastics,
to the stoics and,
and perhaps even beyond them.
The natural laws for hubs are not divine commands or ordinances.
He says,
but they are rules of practical reason.
Figured out,
uh,
by us is the optimal means of securing our wellbeing.
These laws of nature as he describes them,
do not issue a categorical commands so much.
It's sort of hypothetical rules.
If you want x,
do y.
If you want peace,
here are the means to it.
And he calls these laws,
these 19 laws of nature,
the true and only moral philosophy.
So you can see in that passage,
Hobbs takes himself to be a moralist,
writing within the great tradition of moral philosophy.
These laws of nature are for him,
the true and only moral philosophy.
What this brings me to some criticisms or at least some questions about hubs.
This conception of the laws of nature.
What are we to make of these laws?
As I've,
as I've asked before,
in one sense there seems to be a genuine moral content to Hobbs is laws of
nature,
which can be reduced to a single formula.
Seek peace above all other goods hubs more than anyone else wants us to value
the virtues of civility.
That is those you might say summed up in a word or the night with the 19 laws of
nature.
Command,
the civility and tales,
the virtues of peace,
equity,
fairness,
playing by the rules,
pieces for hubs,
a moral good.
And the virtues are those qualities of behavior that lend to peace.
And vices are those that lead to war.
Consider,
uh,
the disadvantages of war.
And the benefits of peace.
Here is what Hobbs writes in such a condition that is the state of nature.
There is no place for industry because the fruit thereof is uncertain and
consequently no culture of the earth,
no navigation nor building,
nor instruments of moving and removing things.
Is it require much force,
no knowledge of the face of the earth.
No.
We'll count of time.
No Arts,
no letters,
no society.
And which is worst of all continual fear and danger of violent death.
Uh,
this is again the sort of existential condition in which Hobbs wants to put us
in the state of nature and all the benefits he lists there he enumerates that
are denied to us in such a condition.
Again,
no,
no knowledge,
no geography,
no cultivation of the earth,
no navigation are building.
All of these things are the fruits of peace.
He tells us.
Yeah.
But at this point,
a careful reader such as all of yourselves,
no doubt,
uh,
would no doubt be suggesting I've gone too far.
Sure.
And suggesting or calling Hobbs,
a moral philosopher whose motto,
uh,
in a way could be summed up in the phrase,
give peace a chance.
Uh,
is that what Hobbs believed?
What,
why is peace the highest good anyway?
I mean,
why not justice?
Why not honor?
Why not piety a,
why not the examined life?
What,
what makes piece so good for Hobbs?
Ah,
well I've given a number of,
I've quoted him on a number of reasons,
but one suggestion might be that it is not so much peace alone at Hobbs
cherishes as life piece is a means to life.
Every creature he says has a builtin desire to preserve itself,
to persevere in its own existence,
to continue in its own steady state.
Uh,
you might say,
and to resist invasion or encroachment by others.
We are all endowed.
He says with a kind of natural right to life.
And the desire to preserve oneself is not just a biological fact,
although it is also that it is for him a moral right.
It is a moral entitlement.
Every being has a fundamental right to its own life.
We not only have a right to our lives,
but to do whatever we regard is needful to protect our lives.
And again,
this is not simply a brute fact of nature.
It is a moral entitlement for hubs,
this source of human worth and dignity.
But now you will suggest I've really gone too far attributing to Hobbs d
doctrine of human dignity that one might expect to find in a philosopher like
can't or someone else didn't.
Hubs cynically,
right?
In chapter 10,
the value or worth of a man is of all things his price,
what,
what we will,
what price we will fetch and the marketplace,
no doubt the value or worth of a man is his price.
Uh,
uh,
I a phrase incidentally quoted by Karl Marx,
to indicate the sheer heartlessness of,
of,
of the kind of the bourgeois society that Hobbes was hoping to bring about and
doesn't Hobbs is materialism.
And his sort of mechanistic theory of nature seemed to detract from any inherent
worth of the individual.
I mean,
there seems to be something to that.
And yet Hobbs certainly regards life.
It's a precious good,
perhaps the most precious good of all.
And he writes with a lively sense of how fragile and endangered,
uh,
life is.
Uh,
the work as a whole can be seen as an effort to dispel what he believes to be
false beliefs,
false doctrines and beliefs that disguise the truth from us.
The truth about the value of life.
For example,
beliefs about the afterlife and all beliefs that detract from,
uh,
an appreciation for the value of life as it is this prevent,
this provides the moral basis of what I would call Hobbs is humanitarianism and
get that humanitarianism seems to raise further problems.
Uh,
doesn't hubs or does Hobbs is attempt to instill in us the readers of his book,
his attempt to instill in us and appreciation for life and the value of life.
Does this simultaneously create an aversion to risk,
uh,
in extreme fear of conflict and challenge or disorder,
you could say is this constant fear that hubs harps on fear of death and the
value of life?
To put it rather rudely,
uh,
is this not another word for cowardice?
Just Hobbs is emphasis and the preservation of life is the supreme moral value.
Does this turn his mighty Leviathan into a kind of Commonwealth of cowards,
uh,
where Aristotle made the courage of men in combat,
central virtue of his ethics hubs pointedly emits courage from his list of the
moral virtues.
At one point,
he even suggests that courage is really just a species of rashness.
And his example of courage comes from duals and dual fighting,
which he says will be always honorable but are unlawful for duals.
He says our many times effects of courage and the ground of courage is always
strength or skill,
though for the most part he says they be effects of rash speaking and the fear
of dishonor in one or both of the competence.
In other words,
courage for him,
again as a form of vanity or pride,
a desire not to appear less than another.
It is a form of rashness.
He says,
and that suspicion is con is it's further carried out in Hobbs is very
interesting treatment of military conscription,
which he talks about a in chapter 21 there he describes battle,
uh,
is he says,
a mutual running away,
two armies confronting one another he describes is a mutual running away.
And furthermore,
he says,
when it comes to conscription,
there should be a,
there should be a allowance made for those that he calls men of natural timorous
snus natural timorous snus cowards.
In other words,
a man that has commanded as a soldier Hobbs rights to fight against the enemy
bill,
his sovereign have the,
has the right enough to punish his refusal with death.
Death May,
nevertheless Hobbs,
right?
In many cases refused without injustice as when he substituted a sufficient,
uh,
sufficient soldier in his place.
Okay.
In other words,
hubs is view of this is why do the fighting yourself,
if you can get someone else to do it for you,
there is no intrinsic virtue in courage or battle.
If you can get somebody else to do the job for you.
It sort of perfect description.
I think of our volunteer army,
uh,
how we pay people to do this,
does it difficult and dangerous work for us?
But the question is,
can even a Hobbsy in society one which insists on rules and so on,
can a Hobbsy in society do entirely without,
if,
if that's,
uh,
if that's my analyst calling,
could you,
could you tell him I'd be a little late,
uh,
discipline for today's appointment?
That'd be good.
Okay.
Um,
anyway,
Kinda Hobbsy in society,
uh,
do without even a hoe do without the,
what we might call them,
the manly virtues,
the civic virtues,
pride,
love of honor that Hobbes seems to condemn.
Consider the case of Ralph Esposito.
Who was the Ralph Esposito you ask.
Uh,
his name is not in the index of Hobbs,
just book.
Uh,
but Mr Esposito,
uh,
is in New York City fireman,
who came to Bradford College,
uh,
to be a masters t guest not long after nine 11
and at length.
Uh,
he discussed there are people like himself who daily risk their lives running
into building,
burning,
burning buildings,
uh,
to rescue total strangers.
Why do people do this?
Is it because some people have a kind of built in sense of Thumos,
you know,
that wonderful platonic term,
pride,
courage,
love of risk that no society,
no,
not even a HUBZone and one can do without,
uh,
even Hobbs is society presumably cannot do without a fire department or a police
department yet if one were to follow Hobbes is risk averse psychology.
If one were to follow the 19 laws of nature that it,
that advise us to seek peace and to avoid conflict.
Why would anyone ever become a fireman?
A soldier?
I'm a risk taker.
A policemen of any sort.
Why would any anyone ever risk one's life for one's country or a cause just to
help other people?
Uh,
people that we don't know and probably will never know.
Um,
even in the passage that I cited earlier where Hobbs describes the benefits of
civil society,
he speaks of activities like navigation,
exploration and industry.
Presumably these are activities that are all engage in risk taking behavior of
one kind or another that seem not to be able to be explained by Hobbs is law of
nature alone.
So the question I want to leave you with today and that I want to pick up again,
uh,
on Wednesday is in the end,
what do,
what do societies require more of?
Do they require more of Hobbes?
Is Men of natural timorous snus or do they require more?
Ralph Esposito's and Anat?
Uh,
we'll finish up hubs on Wednesday.